so when does Bezos come into the picture
and say because that was really out of
left field people are like okay Amazon's
dabbling with this Amazon Prime video
maybe they're gonna do some original
programming whatever but then they buy
just and they buy twitch and we're like
what was that about yeah so what
happened how does that go down we ended
up spinning out Socialcam that one has
its own company when she's a couple
years later sold it to Autodesk they
went for sixty million dollars and
protectable yeah not not bad and then we
ended up you know kept working on twitch
over the years m8 became the CEO is if
he was really the product visionary
behind twitch in the driving force and
then after you know maybe four years of
operation and basically the first six
months of twitch we set these milestones
and it just kind of grew every month it
grew and grew and grew and then
eventually you know basically anything
that gets big enough since Silicon
Valley just kind of interest from all
the fan companies they weren't they're
interested in it and Amazon was was
interested in and I think they saw the
value in the business it was something
the way there's you know there it's kind
of like it was just turning the corner
at the point of being kind of like
Netflix no like Netflix that first
started off you want to see certain
video so you know is it on Netflix and
now you go to Netflix to find something
to watch right right I think twitch had
just was going through that transition
in 2014 where at first I was you started
to go I want to see this certain type of
video or this certain broadcaster or
this sort of content creator and then to
now like oh it twitches a brand when I
associate with certain kind of
entertainment so I'm gonna go there and
watch and so I think twitch had they saw
this like longevity in it and you know
and so that was in 2014 no September
2014 that's the best day of your life up
to that point I think the day of the day
of my life that that had happened I
remember at this time Emmett was running
the company I'm on just on the board of
directors on non-operational in the
company again so I went to Burning Man
yeah and the deal was supposed to close
and I'm like they had my signatures in
escrow or whatever so I don't have to do
anything so I'm like you're on the playa
I'm gonna Burning Man and it rains at
Burning Man and I woke up in a pool of
water because I was sleeping in a little
yurt that we made out of like
construction foam and so I woke up that
is pre you having money so you didn't
have the ability
trailer any also you know you gotta go I
wanted to go in a way that was more
authentic got it I like that part of it
of it so I woke up didn't rain that
night and we didn't tape duct tape are
the tarp honor into the sides of this
concern for in mud so I I woke up in
playa mud and I'd fall later on I find
of mine comes in there's no cell phone
service and friend of mine comes in and
he's like congratulations so I knew was
on wow yeah that's amazing
yeah that was your best burn then that
was it was it was yeah did you go to the
temple and put a justin.tv logo and our
IP rest in peace justin.tv it is such an
amazing like almost decade journey of
like as eight years of crazy ride you
know and five years of it six years of
it was just dismal you know we had fun
times I learned a lot right that's the
most important thing is I you know I was
working with my friends my very good
friends I learned a lot a lot of like I
started from very bad at many things I
was tweeting about this last week but I
started with so few skills right like no
programming's barely any programming
skills horrible management and
leadership skills and didn't really
understand anything about business as
evidence by the fact that we tried to
start a company about me broadcasting
from my camera on my head yeah and I
learned so much through this process
that even the dismal kind of sad times
were very productive at the end of it
you know I look back fondly on them